great games here they've made better
than 14 and again come in off a 46 point
win over Sacramento
Kairi answers yeah you try to go
underneath Tyree he's gonna step away
get a wide-open three Marcus smarts
gonna be coming in next whistle for
Boston they go shooter to the basket has
it rejected out of bounds off all turn
to court look at Irving pull his hands
away and still get the block early
Kyrie avascular love the way he uses his
left hand on the right side to get the
ball up on the glass marco belinelli
stay on the bench at a brief one he's
about to drink I read a very deep three
and he knocks it down there's mine hey
man I'm not going inside and testing
this mess right here I'm letting it fly
from behind as we approach half town
[Applause]
ground
there you go question but I say one
thing offensively they gotta get by get
into the paint just like that play
that's how you do it
what's we calling to the ball could get
to him Tyree looked off the defense to
just let it in a regional smooth crowd
[Applause]
[Music]
Raunak sit down the corner Collins and
Belinelli gonna check in when they can
off the bench Brown again from the
corner got it
back-to-back plays Jalen Brown into
corner for three
Kyrie is his guy find enough hustle to
get to the ball
[Applause]
Irving for two about that early going
hard one way brings it back the other
way wrong foot right handed hooks is up
to three now down to five on the shot
clock
Irene I'll take it and get it punch up
ball touch up
[Music]
Irving takes it makes it your in this
corner right here how you create that
type of space
it's magical Mike it's magical
did you notice the morning-after beat it
go to say the people do a lot if we
believe we believe I read for two more
[Applause]